[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this map is set for one fall approaching
the ring first from Houston Texas
weighing 185 pounds to best ever
Sani far the self-proclaimed best ever
but I've had a chance to get to know
Sammy come on and I would say he isn't
no running for the worst ever
but me just so insincere that's part of
the problem tries to come across as your
best friend next down where he talks
behind your back you know that's the
thing about him I mean he's just a
little bit of a skeevy guy for trying to
sell his panda merchandise got his San
Miguel Ferrer Guevara calm Santa Guevara
vlogs all of his self promotional stunt
and way it's all about saving a bond and
when the pandas were headed back to
China from the San Diego Zoo it looks
like he might have interdicted the
shipment and scout one that's the type
of Cruelty you get for saying [ __ ]
Varma
[Applause]
[Music]
and his opponent from costantino quote
England crema 180 pounds super bad kid
see
[Music]
and if you're staying up late to join us
on itv4 we thank you from the bottom of
our hearts and we hope that you'll join
us we're double or nothing on ITV box
office to see this amazing event oh and
nothing that we have for you tonight but
before that we have super bad hip Savion
making his way to the ring Alex the
handsome hustler who got waylaid by
Sammy davara on Friday at Friday's weigh
in kit slowed by cavora and you know who
to kiss avian pledging revenge his
chance to try this a huge match for both
of these guys put in this position
leading it to double or nothing order
right now if you have not it's
definitely the biggest match of Kip's
avians career but Sammy Gabbar he's been
under the bright lights before he's
at Triple mania tripling on our
promotional partner in Mexico their big
event and he has been there he has won
championships of triple a hips Sabian
you have to wonder the butterflies if
the nerves will affect him if Sammy
Sammy Guevara is able to keep a cooler
head by the way not only a showcase for
two of the top 10 wrestlers in our
industry went the top young referees as
well
Aubrey Edwards getting hurt cyber chance
to shine here in our league wrestling
AAW is for everybody that's not just the
mantra as the bell sounds and the first
ever singles match in all elite
wrestling takes place hips Sabian Sammy
Guevara makin history here in Las Vegas
these guys are both so charismatic right
I mean they are the future of our
wrestling business especially here at
all elite wrestling just such a great
tune up for double or nothing coming up
just a few minutes again don't forget to
order you can stream at bleacher report
lines be our live bleacher report
DirecTV Dish cable providers throughout
the US and
by TV for all other international
occasions accepted the UK and Ireland
that's where you go ITV box-office calm
and Sami Guevara taken the side headlock
you mentioned how charismatic that these
guys are but that will only get you so
far in Olli wrestling they wouldn't be
here unless they were capable and they
are two of the brightest stars the
brightest young wrestlers in the
industry today as Kip Sabian reversing
into an a hammerlock almost the top
wristlock excuse me nope goes over that
top TRS takes down Guevara and crosses
ankles Gabbar though Kip's up and out of
it making it look so easy I'm glad you
talked about charisma only taking you so
far here in all over us and one thing
that's going to make our company
different the fact that pinfalls are
going to matter wins and losses me
something here in aew yeah big
statistics based approach the merit
system still to be unveiled but that is
something that has been one of the
talking points about this promotion and
no will be revealed in the future but
right now Sammy Guevara fighting from
the bottom merit system greater than
buddy system right yeah for sure say
that yes and the leg scissors and Kip
Sabian springs up to his feet escaping
out from Sammy Guevara you can see some
frustration there on Guevara right I'm
not sure how easy he thought this would
be doesn't have a long history with Kip
seda has never fought him before all it
knows the confrontation that took place
Friday as you know being a precursor to
this area thrown back elbow thrown by
Guevara sabians goes up and over the top
SWAT swings through the legs pushing
them off spring
take it down did you get the legs fully
secured but it was enough to disorient
Guevara and bring him up into the
waiting leg lariat from Sabian Sabian
exists it's such a talented individual
just turned 27 years old on May 11th
from Norfolk England at Seaside if you
will debuted on Halloween night in 2010
Norfolk England's own but let me go
Farah Houston Texas is home backflips
over Kipps saving Dropkick takes avian
off his feet
and the best ever soaking in the
admittedly mix 50/50 mix of cheers and
boos here at the MGM Grand Garden Arena
although I think it's the match goes on
fans like saying because are less and
less and are getting more and more
behind tips avian Guevara charting into
the corner Bandera sends him up and over
the top from Sabian Sabian fakes the
drop get boots on the side of the head
catching the bar on the air now Kip's
avian building up a head of steam hits
the ropes up and over the top Guevara
walks it off saving lands on the apron
though Sabian making it look easy
this is again just a precursor to what
you're going to get double or nothing
order now if you have not so simple to
do so DirecTV satellite dish network
cable providers ITV box office
[Applause]
camerman saving guevara surprising
everybody with that diamond for the top
crashing to the floor
Kevon has held 11 different shaping
ships in seven different companies the
biggest of which the triple op she's
away title loss at a little bit earlier
this year but the guy who has had
championship success before at lower
levels trying for that same success here
in alma russell yeah Sammy tomorrow
he was announced for this singles match
prior to the to the the casino Battle
Royale to the format being announced and
I think he was happy he wanted a chance
to shine on his own he didn't want 20
other guys in the ring to potentially
overshadow him he wanted the stage the
bright lights to himself
Sammy Guevara so committed not committed
to adjusting the spine of Kip's Damian
and out laying in some right hands
Aubrey Edwards keeping a close eye on it
Sabian still aware already says he can
continue
[Applause]
Kivar so committed to becoming a pro
wrestler 30-hour drives to work
different shows dragon screw leg whip by
Sabian and now looking for the crew she
on his clutch o brings him over the top
and steps his left leg over to puts even
more pressure even more downward
pressure on the knees of Guevara too
close to the ropes Excalibur that's it
that's a young mistake right
too close to the ropes yes but the
damage may have been done Guevara favors
those high-flying attacks and if he was
if that knee has been tweaked but yes
you're exactly right Alex so if he was
more close to the center he could have
inflicted even more punishment on Kamara
but instead gets the boot up his Guevara
was shocked
powerslam Guevara spins through say
being able to kick out almost had him
right there author Edwards though right
on top of it Sabian did have his
shoulder up before the common floor baby
and did everything in his power to avoid
those consecutive moonsault attacks but
Guevara bringing out a shooting star
pres going directly into the pinning
predicament that's the experience edge
that Guevara brings to this match think
of our needs to be right on top of them
and said you know staring at someone to
ringside that's not the way to be acting
you need to be right on topic tip saving
else is gonna cost you in a big time way
just he's delaying too much of an
opinion stop
too much time given saving a chance to
come back
saving wants this just as much as Sammy
Guevara if not more taking off his feet
and again just an appetizer here a
morsel if you will about what's to come
a double or nothing
pay-per-view coming up penny against
penny against the penny against Chris
Jericho so excited about that it is
going to be under
have that main event alpha versus Omega
2 it's what the wrestling world is
buzzing about you need to order though
Double or Nothing yeah
oh hi common Giri by Kip's ABS grabs the
head rolls through PK tanky
go down into a pity predicament to count
only from Aubrey Edwards justa to Sabian
you can see the gears turning what is it
going to take to put away Sammy Guevara
to make history here tonight not only in
all elite wrestling but professional
wrestling history in the first-ever aew
singles match a we are trending atop the
UK right now
double or nothing on Twitter thank you
so much itv4 Thank You ITV box-office
calm thank you our UK fans for your
support of all elite wrestling Thank You
UK and chefs Ireland as well save Ian
though with that back elbow staggers go
Farah oh go far because a Superman for
yeah that's that short distance Superman
form hashtag aew do
smelling over-the-top hanging on to the
front Chancery was both men on a suplex
on the floor not sure who got the better
of that not sure how Guevara held on not
sure how
give me the better end of that one for
sure and the aew chants have begun here
among the first won't be the last I
could tell you that Excalibur and Gabbar
trying to clear out the front row Jetson
car paint cleared out of the way as
Sammy Guevara laying in shots across the
back of Kip's avian as he's got him
draped across the ring or excuse me
across the barricade
and Sammy Guevara
[Applause]
I thought that was going to be a
guillotine Excalibur I thought after
these beauties brought the leg you know
shooting star press even more velocity
it was a hundred guillotine of sorts
coming from 10,000 feet in the air
Sammy kebab throwing caution to the wind
throwing his body high invoking Jushin
Thunder liger the inventor of this
shooting star press but to my knowledge
leggers never done it quite like that
and by the way this is why we are
trending in the UK number one for double
or nothing and America as well there to
be worldwide who are right about that
looking for a 6:30 right here is Oliver
Guevara up to the top call for 6:30
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
what a debut by Britney's own Kip baby
and in the victory over Sami go far
taken revenge by the way for the wake
Gabbar I disrespected him at the way it
may be this put a little bit more
humility it's a Sammy Guevara into the
few absolutely nothing will thank orange
the humility into the head of Sammy
Guevara but if you're watching us on
itv4 aren't you glad that you stayed up
to see Kip's
savvy and make history here tonight and
I hope you already headed over to ITV
box-office calm to purchase double or
nothing live at the top of the hour
also available on pay-per-view DirecTV
Dish Network fight TV everywhere else in
the world
it skips avian your winner here tonight
in the first ever singles match for all
elite wrestler